Here are the errors that I found.
The direction of this edge here,
should be reversed.
We've exhausted all
the capacity going up.
The remaining capacity on
this edge is going down.
We can unsend the two units
of flow that we sent already.
For this edge here,
there are only two remaining units of
flow that we could possibly
send in this direction.
And there should be five
that we can unsend.
So, those two are wrong.
For this pair of vertices here, we can
indeed unsend three units of flow.
But we actually can't send any
more forward in that direction.
So this edge should be eliminated.
And in this case here,
between these two vertices,
we were sending two units of flow,
so we can indeed unsend them.
But we only have one more unit
of flow that we can send.
So this capacity should be one.